プラ の 皆 さん 底 便 とっ て 好き です か チョコ ミント ず て 僕
めちゃくちゃ 好き嫌い 分かれる
最強 の 食べ物 だ と 思う ん です よ ね 本当 に 好き な 人 は 好き って いう ふう に 嫌い な 人 は
嫌い って いう
こんな に おごれ る も あり まし た が 今 まで で 僕 あまり に その 好き嫌い の 分かれ 方 が 以上 線 って 気
に なっ て アンケート を とっ て み た ん です けど も twitter で アンケート を とっ て み た 結果
好き で で 美味しい って いう 人 は 39%
ちょっと メリー と いっ た が 41%
これ わかん ない です けど なん か 20% すごく ない です か
39% と は 40% って ホ は 人間 人類 の 半分 の 人 が 好き 半分 の 人 は 嫌い えー
こんな に 好き嫌い が 分かれ た の ん ある か な と 思っ て い ます
すごい と 思い まし た
なん で 逆 に 言う と 好き な 人 は めちゃくちゃ そこ 民 時 です し 嫌い めちゃ 素子 と 無理 って いう
が ある 意味 逆 に が
一番 おいしい ん じゃ ない か と うまく 言え ない ん です けど もう ゼロ が 咲く 花 みたい な もん だ と 思う ん
です よ 無理 な 人 から する と 無理 だ な って 言わ れる ん です よ ね もう 好き な 人 から する と
湿気 も 式 な ん です よ
そして ご覧 ください
チョコ ミント アーチ と 8 カ所 が この よう に どれ だけ ある こと が 近く の コンビニ で かるーく 買っ て き た ん
です けど それ だけ で も こんな に 種類 が ある ん です よ ああ 常 に 私 は
チョコ ミント 好き です チョコ ミント に 全然 ちょっと お 話し ましょう チョコ ミント と は 日本 だ と
1974 年 から チョコ ミント で 振れ ば 入っ た みたい で 当時 チョコ ミント と いう 言葉 が 出 た とき は ミント と
いう こと は 広く 知ら れ て おら ず
ハッカ ハッカ
と いう 言葉 で 売ら れ て い た こと が 多かっ た みたい です そう ソ ミン トっ て 何か と 言い ます と
学名 だ と 麺 たって 言う ん です
切り さ 4 今 に 登場 する ニーズ の 免停 に 由来 する 理由 が わかり ませ ん
ミント の 葉っぱ に は 総会 及び ねぇ 量 を 冷やす 感じ を 与える 面 工具 が 風 が 吹く て いる ため ハーブ や
料理 カクテル お 菓子 2 と する もの に よく 使わ れる らしい です けど 今日 の バーガー ミント 好き な 人 に 向け て
作っ て いる 動画 です きれ ない と も 良かっ たら これ を 見 て ちょっと 食べ て みよう か な と か 思っ て
み たら 嬉しい です チョコ みんな も と いう こと 残念 って 人 い たら
ぜひ この 動画 を 機会 に 食べ て み て ください 上 で 1 個 ずつ 食べ て み ましょう
まず 王道 キット カット の チョコ ミント いただき ます
甘い カントリー マアム チョコ ミント いただき ます まあ チョコラ ミント
キャンディー だっ たら すげー チョコ ミント キャンディー まで ある ん です ね おっきい チョコ ミント を いただき ます
まあ チョコ ミント グラン ツ
メイク チョコ ミント ん
まあ カントリー まあ の 蝶 ちょ こみ ん と
うわぁ こんな なんて 呼ぶ ん だ と 多分 ルック だ と 思い ます ねー
ブーブー 1 個 air
って 予選 後半 チョコ ミント に なり すぎ て 味 が 分から なく なり まし た
て ない 私 は 今 ここ に ある すべて の チョコ ミント を 食べ て 思っ た こと が あり ます
持っ て い た
全部 目 ここ で 私 は 思いつい て い
いくら 美味しい と は やっぱり チョコ ミント から 払う と ある ん です よ ね ミント 感 が 強 すぎる と
めっちゃ スースー する チョコ ミント に なっ たら いい な の 民 と 言わ 目 に する と 普通 に なん か あんまり せ ず
し ない けど おいしい チョコ ミント に なっ たり チョコ ミント 味 と いい で も いろんな 要素 が ある わけ です よ
頑張っ てる まず まあ
全て の 庶民 党 を 混ぜる こと に よっ て 再 購入 し チョコ ミント の チョコ ミント が できる の か な と 思い
まし て
アイス も ある ん だっ た のー アイス も チョコ も 全て 含め
すべて の チョコ ミント を 一 つ に 合体 さ せ た 時 史上 最強 に 美味し チョコ ミント の 枷 が できる ん じゃ
ない か と 思い ます ね 全部
a
混ぜ まあ
待っ て 8 a 8 a
お 酒 私 が 今 から やる こと が どう いう 結果 を 生む の か は 分から ない ちょっと し たら まずい か も
しれ ない けど
少なく とも
僕 は 食べ て み ちゃい まい と 思う ん だ けど 頑張っ て に 入り すぎる と バランス 能力 な ん で
ん あ 各自 適量 入れ ましょう って 言う と し た けど もう 無理 に なっ ちゃっ ん だあ ああ ああ ダウ ンっ
Tan jan 10 want you つ の 三 大 ダメ ら 使う より マーニャ バーイ
あー ちょっと グロい な 二 だいたい みんな を 乗せ ぐらい の 量 で お 菓子 を 入れ まし た ん
うまい か も しれ ない で 多分 相手 が めちゃくちゃ 入っ てる ね 襲わ れ な ん です けど もう チョコ ミント シェイク みたい な
感じ に なる の か なぁ と 思い ます お 楽しみ 今 妻
バー
塗り まし た 日本 って
うまい ぞ 多分
クラス の 皆 さん 意外 と 固い なあ と 加瀬 が 多かっ た から ちょっと か バグ に なっ ちゃっ た もん な いっ た
立 しっかり 落ち て き て い ます ただ て ちょこん 人 たち の 協力 に よっ て ロード よう な 的 な
チョコ ミント シェフ が できる の でしょう か さあ 今 0 時 に 入場 です 皆 さん 大きな 鉢 に お 迎え ください
遅い の 正 職 音 が 入っ てる か 柔らかく なる な と 思う ん です けど を 持っ て いる か たい です ね
出 まし た こちら が 現在 町民 状態 の 誇る 決着 で おっ
チョコ ミント の 色 は どこ に 行っ た
そこ で 水色 の 掛け合い が ちょっと イン スタ 倍 と か する か な と 思っ て そこ チョコ ミント の 魅力 の 1
つ か な と 思っ た ん です けど 見 てる 所 し た ただ 大事 な の は 話 です いただき ます
ん me
初心 者 おいしい で な が 多分 これ で 美味しい と いう とても チョコ ミント 次 の 日 に かけ て いく つ です ね
薬 は ベース は ちょっと です ね
非常 に チョ コっ ぽく なっ ちゃい ます だ から やっぱ その 清涼 感 と か スーツ し てる 感 が あっ て とても 食べ
やすい です
ただ 見 た 目 は 砂利 です ね
まっ ちょ こみ ん と 見 た 目 の 良 さ も ウリ の 一 つ な ん でしょう が ちょっと もったい ない な と
思い まし た
ただ で 全然 食べれる か これ は 是非 と も ね チョコ ミント 時 の 皆 さん に は 食べ て い たら
たい 逸品 で ござい まし た
とっても 美味しい です とっても 今回 作っ た から 美味しい ん です けど も まぁ これ を 一言 で まとめる と 混ぜ ない ほう が いい
Me
Me me
あっ はぁ